I don't know if any other personality
course in North America talks about
Vince Wanger and boss anymore.
Maybe not.
But I think their ideas are extremely
interesting and so I'm going to talk
about them.
Um,
they were influenced very much by Martin
Heidegger who was one of the 20th
century's greatest philosophers.
I would say probably this school of,
this is part of the phenomenological
school was more influenced directly by a
philosopher than any other school.
And just to reiterate,
cause you might keep wondering why,
um,
I discussed so many philosophers in this
course.
It's because
clinical psychology in particular is
not strictly a scientific enterprise.
It's because it's oriented towards
values.
As far as I can tell,
I don't,
I don't see that there's any way of
getting around that and that because
what you're trying to do as a clinical
psychologist and perhaps what you're
trying to do with your own life is to
figure out how to live properly.
Now you can construe that as the absence
of illness,
which is,
that's about as close as you get to a
scientific model of living well.
So you don't have any illnesses.
But even the idea of illness is an idea
that's not precisely scientific.
It's,
it's an,
it's an amalgam of scientific concepts
and ethical concepts.
So there's no escaping it.
And if you're in the domain of ethics or
values,
then you're in what is more or less a
philosophical domain.
But also if you're a scientist,
if you're a scientist who's interested
in personality,
it's also something you have to grapple
with conceptually because people live
within an ethic and the ethics
structures their perceptions.
And so even to study human beings as
objects,
you still have to take into account they
ensconced themselves within a value
system.
And you have to understand what that
means.
So for me,
it's easier and more straightforward
just to get right to the root of the
matter to begin with.
And these people also had insanely
interesting ideas.
They're really useful to know.
And so this,
I would say maybe these th the
philosophy that underpins this might be
the most complex of all the philosophies
that we're going to,
that we're going to discuss.
And that's really saying something
because there's no shortage of
complexity.
Say a noon.
So Oh and it's,
it's very difficult to,
to portray what these people were up to.
I started by telling you when we
discussed rogers a little bit,
that the,
the f the phenomenologists were
interested in the fact that people live
within a self defined perceptual world.
That's,
that might be one way of thinking about
it.
Part of the,
part of the way to,
to start to conceptualize what that
means is to consider for a moment,
just consider for a moment how many
things there are in this room that you
might look at.
And the answer to that is there's an
infinite number of them depending on how
you're going to scale your perceptions.
You could spend,
if you were a painter,
you could spend a month painting that
tile,
painting representation of that tile
because it's infinitely complex to get
the colors right to get the patterns
right.
There's no end to it really,
because to make a representation that
was accurate,
it would have to be as detailed as the
thing itself that's crazily detailed
and,
but you don't concentrate on that sort
of thing.
So you think you're surrounded by an
infinite number of potential things to
apprehend,
but that isn't the world you live in.
The world you live in is a very,
very constrained subset of those things.
And part of the question is then what's
the nature of that constrained subset?
That's what you inhabit,
that's what makes up your experience.
And also how is it related to the,
to the infinitely complex objects that
are around you.
And that's really what these people were
trying to figure out.
So you're in this perceptual frame.
That's one way of thinking about it.
That's the design by the way,
that's the,
that's the existential frame or the
phenomenological frame because you can't
think about it nearly as perception
because it contains also all of the
things that you experience subjectively,
the emotions and the,
and the f and the quality that you know,
call Leah is a,
as an element of being that say
philosophers are scientists of
consciousness have a particularly
difficult time with,
and it's like it's the quality of pain.
She doesn't seem reduceable to a set of
objective facts or the quality of color
or the quality of beauty or the quality
of love or the quality of sorrow.
Those things seem your reduceable to
some degree in and of themselves.
Like what?
What is pain made of?
It doesn't even seem like a reasonable
question.
I mean you can say,
how do you decompose the neurological
circuits that are involved in the
experience of pain?
Fine,
but to ask what pain consists of her
compose is composed of,
or what beauty is composed of or love
seems to be.
There's something wrong with that,
with the formulation of that question
because those things sort of manifest
themself as raw facts of existence.
And so their constituent elements of,
of this,
of your field of experience,
you're phenomenal,
phenomenal logical frame or this das
sign,
which is the way that that heidegger
conceptualize it.
That's big there with you at the center
of the center of your what realm of
experience.
So
now here's some characteristics of the
data side.
The thing that you,
the thing that makes up you the past and
the present are implicit in it.
Well,
what does that mean?
say you have a particular emotional
response to something,
maybe it's a negative emotional
response.
And you,
you see this very frequently with
arguments with people.
You're having an argument with someone
you love,
like a family member.
That's a good example.
So let's say it's the same damn fight
you've had with your mother 50 times.
Okay,
well that's interesting because what it
means is that all of those 50 times that
you fought with your mother are implicit
in this fight.
So although it's taking place right here
and now the past is shaped it,
and if you wanted to investigate the
fight come completely,
you'd have to get to the bottom of that
entire train of interactions you've had
with your mother.
So it's implicit in your current,
in your current and your current
experience.
That's one way of thinking about it.
But the future's implicit in it too.
Because what you're doing right now,
it's as if the future is folded up and
what you're experiencing right now and
it unfolds as you interact with it.
And so the reason that it's conditional
to some degree on you and your past is
because it's your past and you that are
determining the actions that you
undertake right now that determine how
the future is going to unfold around
you.
Now,
not,
not completely obviously,
because you don't have complete control
over how things unfold,
but you seem to have some ability to
determine how things unfold.
So one of the ways I've sort of
conceptualize the phenomenological
viewpoint,
this is,
this is one way of thinking about it,
I believe,
is that instead of thinking,
and it does mean you have to
reconceptualize your idea of of objects,
like an object seems like a unit
dimensional thing.
In some sense it's an object.
But most of the things that people
interact with aren't like that at all.
So here's an example.
Let's say you have,
yeah.
Let's say you get a,
you,
you're writing the m cat,
you want to go to medical school,
you've written the Mcat,
you get the envelope in the mail,
it tells you what your score is,
you hold the envelope.
What are you holding?
Well,
if you think about it from an objective
perspective,
it's an envelope.
Who Cares?
It's just a little piece of paper,
right?
It's a little,
it's a rectangle of paper,
but that isn't what you're holding at
all.
That's not what that thing is.
That's how you see it,
but it's not what it is at all.
It's not even,
and you know that your body knows that
because you're shaking.
It's like,
well,
what are you scared of the envelope?
Well,
the,
the fact that you see it as an envelope
is only an indication of just how narrow
your perceptions actually are because
it's a portal,
right?
It's a portal through which you're going
to walk into one of two worlds,
one in which you're in medical school
and the other in which you're not.
And it also actually contains the past,
which is really strange because you
think,
well,
you already know what the past is.
It's no,
you don't.
Whatever that score is in there
determines what your past was.
And you,
you know that too.
You go watch a movie and a bunch of
things happen in the movie and then
something twisted happens at the end and
all of a sudden everything that you
thought about the movie was a wrong and
a whole new path for the movie pops into
being.
Well,
are you a premed student,
a valid premed student?
Well,
the score will determine whether or not
you were very strange,
very strange.
Because you think of the past is fixed.
You know when you think of the things
that you're interacting with as the
things that you see and they're not,
and your body is smarter than that,
way smarter than that because it
responds to,
you could say this is sort of a Rogerian
perspective.
Your body is more likely to respond to
what the thing actually is than how it
is that you see it.
So,
okay,
so the past is implicit in the current
being and the future is implicit in the
current being.
And so the past and the future sort of
folded up inside it and you can unfold
them and take a look at them.
Now here's the next thing.
So from a classic scientific
perspective,
there's the world of independently
existing objects and there's the world
of subjects.
And the subject is really in a secondary
relationship to the object because the
objective world is what's real.
But one of the things that the
phenomenologists were,
were concerned about that is that well,
you run into this problem again of
exactly how it is that you define the
object.
Because
just as the envelope with the scores in
it can't be reduced to the paper.
So the object that you're interacting
with only reveals what it is as a
consequence of the way that you interact
with it.
So for example,
if you take a complex object like
another person,
it's like,
well,
what is it that you are?
While a huge part of that is going to
depend on exactly how I interact with
you because you could be a raging beast
if I interacted with you one way and you
could be a perfectly,
you know,
cooperative entity,
uh,
that was very pleasant if I interacted
with you the other way and another way.
And so partly what's happening,
you could think of what you're
interacting with is something that's
really multifaceted,
truly multifaceted,
and you're,
you say,
well,
you're trying to determine what it is,
but the problem is,
is that what it is manifested itself
only in accordance with how you behave
towards it.
And it's actually the case with even
even objects that you reduce right down
to their constituent elements.
So you might say like,
let's talk about subatomic particles.
Hypothetically,
the most objective thing there is,
well,
it turns out that whether they're a wave
or a particle depends on the way you set
up the experiment.
Now,
I don't want to make quantum analogies,
but what I'm saying is that the object
is a very,
very complicated thing.
And so even defining what it is means
that you have to adopt a frame of
reference with regards to it and you
undertake only some procedures and not
others.
So when you're defining an object,
even scientifically,
you actually don't find,
define the object.
What you say is here's the
multidimensional entity.
If you approach it in this manner,
that's the procedure,
right?
The methods,
if you approach it in this manner,
it will manifest that set of traits.
But the problem is is that there's all
sorts of other traits that it could
manifest just as well if you treated it
a different way.
And so the object itself is not
something that it's,
it's not something easily reducible to a
single set of properties.
I was talking to one of my students
yesterday had a pretty smart thing to
say about images.
We were talking about deep images,
you know,
the sorts that you might see in a really
high quality museum.
So maybe they're voted offs 15th century
or 16th Century Renaissance
masterpieces.
They're inexhaustible to some degree,
which is why they're in museums and
people go look at them decade after
decade.
And it's partly because
every time you look at them,
you're different.
You go in one week,
you look at it,
you see something,
you go in the next week,
you look at it,
you see something else.
Well,
it's partly because you're bringing
something entirely different to the
situation and the image is complicated
enough to allow it to reflect something
new to you.
Depending on the stance you take in
relationship to it and lots of things
are like that.
Lots of things.
I'd like that.
A book you read when you were 16 is
going to be an entirely different book
when you read it.
When you're 35 say,
well the book's the same.
It's like,
it depends on how you define the book
because it isn't even obvious where the
book is.
Exactly.
Well,
it's,
it's on my shelf in the library.
It's like,
no,
that's a chunk of paper that's on your
shelf in the library where exactly the
book is.
That's a much more difficult question
to,
to consider.
So it depends on how you define the
book.
So without a subject,
nothing at all would exist to confront
objects and to imagine them as such.
True.
This implies that every object,
everything objective in barely merely in
being merely objectifies by the subject
is the most subjective thing possible.
Well,
you also know this.
Again,
when you're in an argument with someone,
it's you know it's you know it's you.
It's like you don't know.
Are you being biased or are you,
are you looking at the situation
incorrectly?
The person you're arguing with is going
to convince you that it trying to
convince you that it's your problem.
You could think,
no,
you made me angry.
It's like,
hmm.
An interesting statement.
You know as if you could do that,
but it does seem that way.
You were being provocative while you're
just too sensitive.
It's like,
hmm,
how are we going to settle that?
Well,
it's a continual argument and that that
again,
has to do with the crazy entangled
dynamic between subjective perception
and our objective perception.
I've showed you this before.
I actually think this is a pretty good
schematic representation of what's meant
by Das side.
And this is a complicated little
diagram,
although it,
the diagram itself is quite simple,
but it,
it,
it makes it,
it's predicated on the following
assumptions is that you need to narrow
down your world and what you're doing is
narrowing it down from let's say an
infinite set of possibilities to a
finite set of manageable possibilities.
And you do that a bunch of ways,
partly merely you can't,
your senses aren't acute enough to
detect everything.
So pure stupidity in some sense stops
you from being overwhelmed.
You don't have eyes in the back of your
head,
for example.
So you don't have to worry about all
those things you're not looking at
behind you.
But then it's far more than that.
You just can't handle that full
complexity.
So there's a continual narrowing process
and then you exist inside that narrowed
reality.
Like if I look at you like that,
there's not a hell of a lot of
difference between that and looking at
you like that.
I can't really see these people.
I can tell their people.
That's all I can see your face.
I've got just about all of it right
there.
So that's a very narrow,
and you know,
you're moving your eyes around and
inhabiting this constant narrow space.
Well,
what,
what's that space?
What does that space you inhabit consist
of?
Well,
that's dazzle and that space that you
inhabit.
And so we could say it's something like
this.
You have implicit in that perception,
a sense of where you are and what you're
doing right now.
It's in the perception and then in the
perception as well is what you're aiming
at because you're not just sitting here
passively or you'd be asleep or you'd be
unconscious.
You're sitting here doing nothing,
you know physically,
but you have an aim in mind.
And the aim is what you're pointing your
eyes at.
The aim is what's structuring your
perceptions.
They aim is what's revealing that part
of the world,
that that is being revealed to you,
to you.
That's the revelation of the world.
It also structures your emotions.
It also primes your behaviors.
So it's not a drive,
it's not a goal.
It's not a,
it's not a motivation.
It's,
it's,
it's more than that.
It's all of that at once.
That's sort of what your personality is,
but you see the phenomenologists don't
really think about personality.
They think about the manifestation of
your reality.
It's not exactly your personality.
It's that you're the center of a reality
and you,
you constitute that reality.
But all your elements of experience
constitute that reality.
And so it's something like it's simple.
Its element is something like where you
are,
where you're going and the embodied
actions you undertake to relate those
two things,
which would include your eye movements.
Cause of course perception is an active
phenomena.
You are shaking your eyes back and forth
unbelievably rapidly.
Otherwise give,
you can,
if you can make your eyes stand still,
which you can do with great
concentration,
everything we'll black out because you
have to move your eyes back and forth so
that the light hits different cells
because the cells get exhausted and then
they stop reporting.
So you're just whipping your eyes back
and forth in micro micro way constantly.
And as well as moving them around
voluntarily and involuntarily.
So even perception,
his perception is a lot more like
feeling things out with your fingers.
Even when you're using your ears or your
eyes very active.
There's no passive perception.
It's a motor act to perceive.
And so that motor act is determined by
your hierarchy of values.
That's one way of looking at it.
So another way of thinking about it,
that's also how the past and the future
implicit in it,
you're a very active perception is
determined by your entire value
structure.
So it's implicit inside of it.
It's folded up inside of it.
You can tell that too,
because if something violates it,
again,
maybe an argument with someone,
because people are,
it's good to think about people as the
thing you interact with the most as as
the canonical object because they're so
damn complicated and they get in the way
all the time.
And when someone gets in the way of what
you're doing,
you know,
it isn't obvious what they're
interfering with.
It might be the little micro routine
that you're undertaking right now.
You know,
maybe you go home and you make a nice
dinner and the person you're making it
for is all rude about it.
Okay.
So what exactly are they getting in the
way of?
Well,
they're certainly getting the way in the
way of your expectations of having a
nice emotional time for the next hour,
but you have no idea how indicative that
is of some serious flaw in you or them
or the relationship or the situation or
the way you've conducted your whole life
or the way they've conducted their whole
life.
And all of that's packed in there.
It's sort of like the unconscious of the
psychoanalysts,
but it's more,
it's more,
it's,
it's not the same conceptualization.
It's another way of looking at the same
phenomena.
So,
okay.
All right.
So the two people we're going to talk
about most are made our boss,
and he was influenced by Martin
Heidegger,
who was a great philosopher,
taken to task often because he turned
out to be tangled up with the Nazis more
than he should have been.
And Husserl.
That's Edmund Husserl who was actually,
if I remember correctly,
mark,
Mark Martin,
heidegger's teacher that's living being
swagger.
And they were,
both of these two people were influenced
both by Freud and Yung.
Okay.
So here's one of been swaggers claims.
I love this claim.
It's such a cool idea and I think
there's neurological support for it.
Neuropsychological support,
what we perceive our first and foremost,
not impressions of taste,
tone,
smeller,
touch.
Not even things or objects,
but meanings.
Well that's an interesting idea because
your claim,
they,
you know,
it's been said that every person is an
unconscious exponents of some great
philosopher's presuppositions.
Well,
mostly the way you think about the way
you perceive is that there are objects
in the world.
You see the objects,
you think about the objects,
you evaluate the objects,
you decide how to act on the objects,
and then you act right.
It's from,
okay,
object sense,
perception,
emotion,
cognition,
action.
That's wrong.
That isn't how it works.
It's partly not the way it works because
you're actually,
the way that you interact with the world
exists at multiple levels.
So,
for example,
you have reflexes.
So if I,
if I,
if I poke you hard,
you'll react like that.
He'll jerk back.
And that you do that without thinking.
That's part of a neurological circuit
that's very deeply embedded and that's
virtually automatic.
It's reflexive,
it doesn't require conscious perception
at all.
It's too slow for starters.
And so you have multiple layers,
there's multiple levels of you
interacting with the world.
And at one level you're seeing objects,
you're thinking about them,
you're planning what to do,
but you're doing all sorts of other
things that are way faster than that and
other things that are way slower at the
same time.
Now what,
what Ben Weighing Wanger claims is that
what you see in the world,
our meanings and that.
So it's the meaning detection first and
the object recognition second.
Now that's a hell of a claim that is,
but,
but there's definitely levels of your
nervous system that operate in that
manner.
So for example,
here's a good example.
People have blindsight there,
dad,
their core visual cortex is damaged.
They can't see objects.
So they think they're blind.
But if you show them an angry face,
they'll manifest a change in the skin
conductance.
They'll orient and it means that the
eyes are still mapping the face onto the
Amygdala and the Amygdala is mapping the
pattern onto the body.
No object perception pattern,
pattern,
no object perception.
And so the meaning is what's,
what's the meaning is what's being
perceived first and foremost,
you have to perceive meetings first
because you actually want to stay alive.
That's the trick.
So the world is full of these things
that have meanings to you,
that are relevant to your survival and
what you're,
what you're perceiving first is the
relevance of the pattern to your
survival.
And the idea that you can conceptualize
that as a set of objects.
Well first of all,
that's a pretty new idea technically
speaking,
right?
Because technically speaking,
we didn't really start to conceive the
world as subject in an objective world
until we really formalized science.
Now,
science was implicit long before it
became explicit,
but it didn't become explicit until
about 500 years ago.
So you react to meanings.
So here's an example.
Babies.
If you,
if you have two surfaces and you put a
piece of glass between them,
they're elevated and you put an eight
month old baby on one surface or so,
they can crawl,
the baby can crawl,
it won't crawl across the space.
And you might say,
well it's sees a hole and we'll walk.
Won't crawl across it.
But that isn't what it sees.
It sees a place to fall off direct.
That's direct perception.
So when I see this,
for example,
my eyes see that as a pattern.
That patterns on my retina,
it's propagated through my optic nerve.
It's propagated into my brain.
It's propagated on to my motor cortex
and the propagation is this,
that right?
So I can pick it up and as soon as,
when I look at that,
this is implicit.
That's implicit in the perception.
You think,
well why do you see that at the size and
resolution you see it at?
That's why.
So the fact that you see it that way has
this implicit in it and is it that you
see the object and match your hand to
it?
It's that matching your hand to it.
Is part of the perception of the object.
It's what gives the object meaning and
so you see actually you perceive the
meaning of the object.
It's part of the perception and you
can't not see the meaning of the object
while you can.
If you're a scientist,
you can sort of separate the out the
object from its meaning.
That's actually what science does.
It tears the object away from its
meaning and then of course there's
nothing meaningful left and so sorry and
sands up value free,
but that's because of the meaning has
been torn out of it.
Now there's technical reasons for doing
that,
but Ben swingers point is don't kid
yourself.
You see the meaning first.
Here's an example.
You Watch the trade taller towers fall.
What did you see
while you could say,
well,
you saw the towers fall.
It's like,
why are you in shock for two days
afterwards then?
Well,
because the towers aren't,
what are the towers exactly?
As long as they're standing and
operating their towers,
as soon as they fall,
God only knows what they are.
Maybe they're the beginning of the next
war.
You know?
Who knows what they are.
And so everyone was in shock for three
days because what they saw was the
indeterminate meaning of that event and
it opened all sorts of gateways.
It's like,
well,
the towers fell.
There's gateways open everywhere.
We don't know what's going on.
We don't know what's going to happen
next.
We don't know where we are.
And that's direct perception mapped onto
your body.
Bang,
you're in shock.
You see the meaning first and while you
constrain it down to well,
why are you so upset while the towers
fell?
It's like that's the best you can do for
a verbal utterance.
It's,
it's what your perceptual systems
reported to you,
but God only knows what happened.
We still don't really know what it meant
that they fell.
Now most things have put themselves back
together,
but,
and then you think,
well,
what does it mean?
What does it mean that what you see
first is the meaning?
And that's a really tricky question
because he might say,
well that's,
that's when you get back to the problem
of what constitutes real.
So I could say,
well,
you've evolved to see the meaning.
Well then we might ask,
well,
if you've evolved to see the meaning and
that's kept you alive,
is there anything more real than the
meaning?
Because it's somebody who's a
materialist would say,
well no,
the object is more real.
It's like no,
it depends on how you define real.
It might be that the most real thing
about the visual cliff is that that's a
falling off place and that it's
secondary description has a,
you know,
an object,
a hole or something like that.
That's just a,
that's something you paint over top of
the primary reality and so
well here's the and here's the practical
application of it.
Or at least one of the things that I
think is practical.
You know,
you can have experiences that did differ
in their,
let's call it high quality meaning you
know,
so you get engaged and engrossed in
something and you're happy about that.
It's not that you're happy,
it's that you're engaged and engrossed
in it.
You would do it again even though it
might take,
take effort.
You can tell that where you are is
meaningful.
Well,
I think what happens in that situation
is that you're in a pia jetty and place
where many of the games that you're
playing are stacked sort of isomorphic
Lee on top of one another,
and the experience of meaning is the
fact that you're playing the small game
properly nested inside a larger game.
You're playing it properly,
nested inside a larger game,
you're playing it properly to et cetera.
All the way out past is balanced,
future is balanced,
everything is stacked up and there's a
report coming from your being telling
you that that's why you're engaged.
Might say,
well,
maybe that's real.
Maybe it's more real than anything else.
It's a strange thing because if you
think that meaning is separate and
secondary from the real objective world,
then the reality is the object,
but it isn't obvious that the reality is
the object.
It's certainly,
it's certainly not how we act.
It's not how we perceive,
and so did we evolve to perceive
reality?
It depends on what you mean by
perceived.
Perceived might mean,
did we evolve mechanisms that allowed us
to survive in the face of that reality?
Yes.
Is that what's real?
What enables you to survive in the face
of reality?
It's a definition.
It's a perfectly reasonable definition.
Unless you can come up with a better
one.
Meanings are primary.
Now that brings up,
that brings up a strange issue.
So what determines the meaning of what
it is that you're perceiving?
Well,
this is where been swagger and boss
disagree.
Then Wagner says it's,
it's the a priori ontological structure,
the world design or matrix of meaning.
Okay,
so what does that mean?
Well,
you have a particular history,
biological and cultural and individual
and you're viewing the world through the
lens of that,
of that set of particular already.
So it's almost as if you're behind a
curtain and the curtain has certain
holes in it and you can see through the
holes in the curtain and the curtain is
your construction.
So the curtain with the holes determines
what you see.
Well,
boss would say no.
It's the opposite in in a very strange
thing.
It's that the meaning of the world
manifests itself to you more or less of
its own accord,
and it's a tougher one to explain.
Disclosure of meaning boss,
the revelation of the object,
the emergent emergence of the
phenomenon,
the numinous,
the very word phenomena is derived from
famous thigh to shine forth to appear to
unveil itself,
to come out of concealment or darkness.
Okay,
here's an example.
You see someone beautiful,
your perception or is it your perception
or does the beauty exist?
That's the difference between Vince
Wanger and boss has been swagger would
say,
well,
the reason that that thing appears to
you as beautiful is because of the way
you're filtering it,
and boss would say,
no,
the beauty is in Hay inheres in the
object itself and manifest itself.
It's forth and so I really liked this
concept,
this,
this cannot concept of phenomenon.
That's why they're phenomenologists
famous die means to shine forth from,
from the phenomenological perspective,
you pursue those things that shine
forth.
Now remember,
this is kind of a parallel idea.
I suppose it's a parallel of union
ideas.
You remember in Harry Potter that when
they're playing quidditch,
he's always chasing the snitch and you
remember how if,
if I've got this correctly,
quidditch is basically two games at the
same time,
right?
There's the standard game and then
there's the game that the seekers play.
Yes,
I've got that right.
What happens if the secret gets the
snitch?
Game's over,
right?
They win.
Very interesting.
It's brilliant.
She has a brilliant imagination that a
woman rolling.
So the idea is that in every game
there's two games going on at the same
time.
There's the ordinary game and there's
the game that the seekers play and the
secrets chase,
the thing that shines out and that's
what that little thing is the snitch.
It's a round circle with wings.
It's a very,
very old,
old,
old symbol.
It's a symbol of what?
It's a symbol of reality before it's
fractionated into its parts.
I don't know how to say it anymore
clearly than that.
It's a symbol of,
it's a symbol of what?
Managing that.
There are things that move forward to
make you curious and you were trying to
figure out what was common among all the
things that made you curious.
That thing that Harry Potter is chasing,
that's a symbol of that.
It's golden,
like the sun,
it flits around and attracts your
attention and it's always moving.
And if you're seeking,
you chase it.
So that's the phenomenological idea.
That's the disclosure of meaning.
You say,
well when you're curious about
something,
why are you curious about that?
Is it,
is it calling to you or is it something
that you're interpreting?
Well,
I would say it's both.
I think that's the way to resolve this
puzzle.
It's that there isn't a perceiving
entity without a structure and your
structure has been evolving itself for
three and a half billion years.
There's no perceiving entity without a
structure,
but by the same token,
the thing that's being perceived also
shines forth with its own potential
manifestation.
And you need to think of it both ways at
the same time.
But the curiosity issues,
it really,
it's fascinating.
One,
because curiosity pulls you forward.
It's not random.
That's the thing that's so cool.
You can't really control it,
but it's not random.
If your curiosity is random,
your schizophrenia and,
and I mean that technically because one
of the things that happens to
schizophrenia is that the mechanisms
that establish relevance become
pathologized and they see meaning
everywhere randomly,
and that's partly why they generate
delusions because they,
the incoherent manifestation of meaning
calls out for a representation.
They develop a paranoid delusion if
they're intelligent enough to put
everything together,
but so you're curious and something
pulls you forward will you can,
you can interact with the curiosity and
you can follow it,
but you can't really direct it.
The question is where is it taking you?
So that little ball,
that was a manifestation of what the
Greeks referred to Greeks.
Is that right?
We're curious is Roman and Greek God,
we're curious.
The spirit Mercurius is this thing.
It's the messenger of the gods,
the winged messenger of the gods.
It flits around.
You say,
well,
the curiosity pulls you forward to where
while to whoever,
wherever it wants to take you.
Well,
that's a union idea as well.
Is that your curiosity?
Is like the manifestation of yourself to
the ego,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's the thing that you could be in the
future calling you forward.
Something like that.
Very strange ideas.
Very interesting.
See,
when you start to understand that you're
not in control of what makes you
interested in things,
the whole world shifts around on you.
Because the question is if you're not in
control of that,
what the Hell is directing it?
What's going on?
It's not you.
It's not under your control.
It's not random.
It's alive.
It's dynamic.
It has an orientation towards something
that's the union self or that's the
manifestation of meaning.
Yes,
very strange.
I told you this already.
See there's a,
there's an old representation of very
old representation of the snitch right
there.
Now this is old symbol a.
You've got this dragon of chaos here.
It's kind of like an octopus as well.
That twist and its tail refers to
infinity dragons.
Almost always have an infinite tail like
that.
It's got the claws of a bird,
maybe a bird of prey,
the body of an animal and the head of a
snake.
And then down here you see it's got the
sun up there.
So it sort of aiming at upward towards
the sudden this thing.
And then down here is this thing called
the round chaos.
It's an old l chemical system.
And if you look that dragon is
fertilizing this and that has potential
in,
it's like an egg.
It's full of potential.
And so it's matter and spirit at the
same time.
It's sort of like it's,
it's a,
it's a representation of that which
you're exploring because you could say,
well,
the thing that you're exploring sort of
a constructivist idea,
you explore something new,
what you generate from the exploration
you,
because as you explore it,
you learned things that changes you.
So you generate psyche out of the
exploration,
that spirit,
and he also generate the world out of
it.
But the thing to begin with,
his psyche and world at the same time,
and that's what this thing represents
and that's what Harry Potter is chasing.
That's what makes him a seeker.
Very strange ideas.
Now I'm going to tell you a dream and it
was a dream I had when I was working on
these ideas and I'm going to tell you
the dream for two reasons.
One is because it bears directly on
these ideas and two because while we
just covered psychoanalytic thought and
I want to show you how a dream can work
because it's not easy to find a dream
that you can interpret in a way that's
public that makes sense because they're
usually so tightly defined contextually
you can them in the therapeutic context
context cause you know so much about the
person.
It's very hard to pull that out and make
it meaningful outside of that context.
But this dream works.
Okay,
so I was dreaming,
I was dreaming that there was a small
object,
it was a circle,
a sphere about this big and it was
floating on top of the Atlantic Ocean.
And I was,
I had a kind of a bird's eye view of it
and I was following it along like maybe,
you know,
like a drone would follow behind an
object and it was floating and it was,
it was really zipping along,
man.
It was really,
really fast.
And then the scene shifted to a bunch of
scientists.
They were sitting inside a room full of
television monitors and they were
watching this thing move across the
ocean.
And so it was here and then there were,
it was,
it had four hurricanes beside it,
one here,
one here and one here.
So it was in the center of four
hurricanes.
So whatever it was was like some bloody
potent thing was zipping across the,
it was zipping across the ocean.
Then the scientists got a hold of it,
I guess in the scene shifted.
And I was in a museum,
like an old Victorian museum and this
thing,
this ball was now inside a wood.
So imagine a would stand with a glass
case on top of it.
It was inside the glass case and it was
floating and it was sort of pulsing a
little bit.
And so inside the room there was Stephen
Hawking
and the American president,
I don't remember who it was.
He was sort of faceless,
but Steven,
I thought Stephen Hawking,
what the hell?
Disembodied intellect that Stephen
Hawking.
So that's what that meant.
And the president,
well he's just dissemble of order.
And so this thing,
whatever it was that was surrounded by
these winds had been placed into a
category system,
right?
It's in a museum.
It was boxed in.
It had been conceptualized in
categorized partly by disembodied
intellect.
That was Stephen Hawking and partly by
social order.
And so there's a bin Swinger boss thing
going on there.
The thing pulses and is alive.
So it's got its own power,
but it's also encapsulated in a category
system.
So I'm a third person observer in there.
I'm not in the room,
I'm just seeing this.
So that was fine.
So the next thing that happened,
oh he has one of them described the
features of the room.
It's walls were seven feet thick.
They didn't want this thing going
anywhere and it was made out of titanium
dioxide.
And I thought,
what the hell is that?
Well,
it's a paint,
it's a paint substance,
but it's also what the hall of the
starship enterprise is made out of.
So,
so my dream was saying,
well what's the hardest substance there
is as well?
It's titanium dioxide.
It's not getting out of that box.
The walls were designed to permanently
constrain the object.
Okay.
Now the next thing that happened was
this object was,
it was,
you could tell it was kind of alive and
it kept shifting around.
And at one point it turned into a
Chrysalis,
a cocoon.
And I thought,
what the hell does that mean?
And then so it,
it turned into a cocoon.
And I don't know if you've seen it
Chrysalis when it's just about to hatch,
but it's,
it twitches around day.
It's alive,
that thing.
So they're very strange things.
And then at the end it turned itself
into a pipe,
like a mirror show on pipe.
And I thought then it reformed itself
and do his fear and just shot right out
of the room.
Like,
like the walls weren't even there.
It was just decided it was gone.
Bang,
it was gone.
And I woke up and I thought,
what the hell?
What the hell does that mean?
It took me forever to figure this out.
So then about two years after
experiencing this dream,
I was reading Dante's inferno in the
ninth Canto,
a messenger from God appears.
So Dante goes down into hell.
And it was,
Dante is attempt to describe.
It's brilliant.
It's so imagine that you go to a bad
place psychologically,
right?
So your life has collapsed,
that's terrible.
But then you're trying to figure out
what you did wrong and how you're to
blame for it.
And so what you do is a descent,
a descent into your own foolishness and
stupidity level by level,
by level.
And that's what Dante was trying to
explain.
That's what that hell was.
Levels of catastrophe.
And there's something right at the
bottom.
And he found that it was betrayal that
was at the bottom.
So in any case,
I was reading that and there's a line in
there that made me remember the stream
cause I tried to figure out the stream
for years.
Hey,
I'm in the ninth count to a messenger
from God appears in hell to open the
gate of Disse,
which is barring the divinely ordained
with a virtual in Dante.
The approach of this messenger,
an angel ms proceeded by a great storm
described in the following manner.
Suddenly they're broke on the dirty
swell of the dark marsh,
a squall of terrible sound that sent a
tremor through both shores of hell as
sound as if to continence of air.
One frigid and one scorching clashed
head on in a war of wins that strips the
forest bare,
ripped off whole boughs and blew them
helter skelter along the range of dust
it raised before making the beasts and
shepherds run for shelter.
So that was like a herald of the arrival
of this messenger.
It's a very powerful scene.
And I thought about this dream with this
thing with the four storms.
So the pipe thing that really,
that really,
that took me forever to figure out,
and I find the remembered this painting
by an agreed,
this is not a pipe,
right?
So what does that mean?
Well,
what it means is the representation is
not,
the thing is a very famous painting,
right?
The representation is not the thing.
Well,
even the perception is not the thing.
And that's what the dream was trying to
get at.
It's like this thing,
this thing that was so powerful and so
capable of transforming could be
encapsulated temporarily within a
conceptual system.
But whenever it decided to leave,
it was just going to leave.
And so what it was referring to was the
potential that there is inside objects.
So for example,
and it's such a complicated thing to
explain,
nobody knew what cell phones were going
to do.
You make the cell phone,
you think you know what it is,
you don't know what it is.
No one knew what the birth control pill
was going to do.
You make it,
you think you know what it is.
You have no idea what it is.
And it's going to do some of the things
you think it will do and it's going to
do a bunch of things you have no idea
about.
And that's because the things are more
complex than they look.
They're multidimensional and they have,
I wouldn't say a life exactly,
but they have an intrinsic complexity
that tends to unfold across time and
it's only somewhat predictable.
And so you have things under your
control and in your grasp to some
limited degree,
but at any point,
it's like the switch and the Yin Yang
symbol.
At any time,
chaos can collapse into order or the
order can collapse into chaos.
And that's what that dream meant.
Another painting by him,
a Greek trying to express the same
thing,
right?
All men in suits,
all uniform,
all thinking the same way,
same haircuts,
completely socialized,
blinded by their own perceptions.
That's us because you think,
well,
your perceptions aluminate and bring you
information.
It's yes and no.
They also constrain to equal degree.
I dreamed much later about a year later,
this was a very cool image too.
You know that image that I think it's,
is it Da Vinci or Michelangelo of the
manned inscribed in the square?
Inside the circle.
It's a very famous image.
What it was like that,
except it was a cube but not a square.
And so there was a kind of a faceless
person,
almost like a mannequin inside this
cube.
And he was suspended about two feet off
the ground.
And on the front wall it was like
wallpaper designs.
There was these little squares about
this big and they were Mandela's square
with a circle inside them.
And then inside the circle there was a
little snake tail that was out and the
whole wall was covered with the snake
tails and the person,
when the person walked forward,
the wall would move forward.
And when he moved,
walked backwards,
the wall would move backwards.
It was always this far away and he could
reach out and pull any of those snakes
into being.
And so that was another dream of the
same sort of idea.
What do you have in front of you?
A world of objects?
No,
you have a world of potential in front
of you and you can interact with any
aspect of that potential and while
you're doing so,
you realize it,
you,
you pull something into being that
wouldn't have been there before and what
you see in front of you is a a wall of
potential.
The potential is not infinite because
you're constrained,
but it's still,
it's,
for all intents and purposes,
it'll do you just fine.
It's more potential than you could ever
need and so the dream see dreams.
Dreams are at the forefront of thinking.
They get there before you.
The creative imagination is at the
forefront of thinking.
It's trying to you.
If you think that you're moving out into
the unknown to gather new information,
what gets there first is the
imagination.
Obviously that's what Piaget said about
children as well.
You imagine at first,
then maybe you can represent it in
speech and dream is part of that
imaginative process.
That's what artists are doing.
They're take going out into the unknown
and representing it imaginatively and
said,
well,
what does that painting mean?
While if the artists knew that,
he'd just write it down,
right?
The art is beyond what's what's
articulable otherwise it's not art.
It's just propaganda.
So the artists and the dream,
they're out on the frontier,
right?
That's the open imagination.
And so when you're conceptualizing new
things,
the dream in the imagination can bring
you places that you don't even know that
you can go.
And it's a mystery too.
It's like,
I don't know how I figured this out.
I didn't.
It was as if the figuring out manifested
itself inside me because that's the
experience in a dream,
right?
You don't feel,
I dreamed this up.
You feel I had a dream.
Where did that come from?
Springs out of the unknown and offer
something to you.
Man's option to respond to this claim or
to choose not to do seems to be the very
core of human freedom.
Here's pathology has conceptualized by
the phenomenologists.
It's a very interesting way of thinking
about it.
Existential guilt and fear as debt to
possibility.
Well,
so there's this idea,
it's like an existential idea that you
have some problems,
that you have some problems in your
life.
Well,
the part of the design is the sense of
responsibility that you have to address
those problems.
It's part and parcel of the way that
human beings manifest themselves in the
world.
So part of your pathology would be
failure to bear,
the responsibility for your being and
the sense that you have a debt to
existence,
and according to the phenomenologists
that's built right into the sense of
you're being failure to shoulder
existential burden,
results in neurotic,
guilt and fear.
It's a remarkable conceptualization,
unpaid debt to existence.
Clean up your room.
Right.
Well,
that's a good place to start.
Stop.
Okay,
good.
We'll see you in a week and a half.